hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
ryan right today I'm going to be
covering the news that I found most
interesting in the third week of
September 2015 in three minutes or less
Rachel McAdams is confirmed to be a part
of the cast for Marvel's Doctor Strange
no details have been released on the
character shall be plain but what does
it matter we have another excuse to jerk
off to her writers Simon Kinberg is
hoping to redeem himself by making a
better sequel to Fantastic Four in the
words of frozen let it go let it go my
version goes smack a ho smack a ho looks
like Jack Reacher to is gonna bring back
Tom Cruise and now cast his daughter she
joins the ranks of spoiled child actors
who didn't really have to work hard at
all again in the movie business versus
Jaden Smith now there's axline her son
and batman be superman and now um I mean
she's [ __ ] hot out of his a team's
[ __ ] hot Sun ok Elizabeth Banks is
and talks to direct and produce the
Charlie's Angels reboot in case you guys
don't know who she is her famous and
most respected work was that of the
shower head masturbation scene in the 40
year old virgin how hot was she wore of
the Planet of the Apes has cast actor
Woody Harrelson reports speculate that
when the aves win they will celebrate by
passing around a joint
getty cos woody harrelson smokes weed he
smokes weed everyone likes weed in
california i like we butcher Chewbacca
is getting his own comic books spin-off
by marble reports say that to appeal to
an even bigger demographic Chewbacca's
history will be revealed that he is
actually black anyway guys that's it for
my movie news of the week if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
periscope and last but not least you can
catch my videos on Latino Review com run
by a guy named Kelvin Kelvin I saw you
pee I thought you'd be a little bigger